[Music]
hey guys welcome to their installments
of Harry Potter theory in this video
going to be discussing curses or more
specifically the signature purple curse
of infamous Death Eater antonin de la
vie
Anton de Lahav was a dark pure blood
wizard and one of Lord Voldemort's most
loyal followers he was involved in both
the first and second Wizarding wars and
was responsible for torturing countless
muggles and non supporters of the Dark
Lord the following excerpt from the
Goblet of Fire depicts tal Hoffs nature
there was antonin dollar HOF I I saw him
torture countless muggles and non
supporters of the Dark Lord he was born
sometime before the year 1950 and was
described as having a long pale twisted
face dark hair and a burly build
Dolokhov was notably one of the Death
Eaters that traveled to Hogsmeade along
with Tom Riddle when Voldemort attempted
to take the defense against the dark
arts position at Hogwarts then if I were
to go to the hogshead tonight I would
not find a group of them not Rozier
Mostafa da Lahav awaiting your return
devoted friends indeed to travel this
far with you on a snowy night merely to
wish you luck as you attempt to secure a
teaching post Dumbledore once says to
Tom Riddle Dolokhov was one of the most
powerful Death Eaters after Bellatrix
Snape and possibly Barty Crouch jr. and
was personally responsible for defeating
the powerful aura mad-eye Moody Remus
Lupin and even the Pruitts though he
always performed quite well in battle
dollar Hobbes perhaps most humiliating
moment was when he was put face to face
with Ron Hermione and Harry in a Luchino
cafe jewel Hermione was able to take
control of the situation but dollar
haave in a full body bind curse then
altered his memory however the trio were
also instrumental in stopping Voldemort
so no surprises there really doe Lahav
among other things was highly skilled at
Transfiguration the dark arts dueling
nonverbal magic charms and most
important of this video spell creation
dollar HOF was responsible for the
creation of the famous purple jet that
seems to only come out at the end of his
wand the following excerpt
the order of the Phoenix show Salah have
spell in action but the Death Eater
Hermione had just struck dumb made a
sudden slashing movement with his wand a
streak of what looked like purple flame
passed right across a mine his chest
she gave a tiny Oh as though of surprise
and crumbled onto the floor where she
lay motionless the after-effects of
being struck by said spell were
described as follows she winced slightly
and put a hand to her ribs the cursed a
Lahav had used on her though less
effective than it would have been had he
been able to say the incantation aloud
and nevertheless caused in Madame
Pomfrey x' words question of damage to
be going on with dalla have also used
the spell on Howry but it was blunted by
his shield charm nevertheless Harry
described the impact that it did make
like a streak across his face like a
blunt knife the curse even knocked him
off of his feet breaking down this curse
there are a few things that we can
confirm number one it doesn't cause any
science a visible damage we know this
because my knee had no visible cuts
bleeding or marks after being hit with
the curse however she was very much in
pain this suggests that the curse causes
some sort of internal injury number 2 no
incantation is required but perhaps
weakens the effects if not said aloud
after doll ha famously uses the curse on
Hermione and when Hermione is nursing
her injuries it is expressed that the
curse was less effective than it would
have been had he been able to say the
incantation aloud and number three it is
blockable but not entirely this is
proven because Harry's shield charm did
have some effect against it however he
did still feel some of the effects of
the curse this could be because the
spell is not entirely blockable by
anyone it could be because Harry's
shield charm was not strong enough or it
could just be because dollar HOF was too
strong for Harry Dolokhov uses the spell
several times during the battle of the
Department of mysteries and is the only
known practitioner but does that mean he
created it or is this Bell just
relatively unknown in the Philosopher's
Stone there is actually another
reference to a purple flame much like
the one that we see here to my knees
chest he pulled open the next door both
of them hardly daring to look at what
came next but there was nothing
frightening in here just a table with
seven differently shaped bottles
standing on its Enlai
Snape's said Harry what do we have to do
they stepped over the threshold and
immediately a fire sprang up behind them
in the doorway
it wasn't ordinary fire either it was
purple the same instant black flames
shot up in the doorway leading onward
they were trapped this excerpt of course
refers to the sixth obstacle defending
the Philosopher's Stone given Snape's
history with the Death Eaters and that
this is the only other reference to a
purple flame from the books I think the
dollar Hoff signature curse is possibly
just a curse talk to powerful Death
Eaters and may not be a spell that he
created by himself at all there's lots
of fire based magic in Harry Potter
fiend fire protego diabolica
the carnem inflam re etc but not much of
its purple we also know that witches and
wizards have spell preferences they have
their go twos so maybe this purple flame
is just dollar house go-to and because
he's the only one who uses it it became
associated with him alternatively if
Dolloff did invent the spell which is
very possible given that he is a
powerful wizard I'd imagine that it is a
combination for known virus spell
unknown purple spell one purple spell
that comes to mind is the revulsion jinx
or relatio which is known to repel and
emits a purple light when cast though
the revulsion jinx is usually defensive
it could also be used offensively
particularly if it is combined with
another firey
offensive spell one via spell that
immediately comes to mind is Incendia
okay the fire-making charm which we know
is used to set things on fire
however this spell doesn't really have
much application in dueling
alternatively it could be a combination
of relatio and an extremely tuned down
fiend fire which is also known as cursed
fire this would sort of make sense given
that dollar 1/2 spell is referred to as
a curse if we knew the incan tation we
could figure out a lot more what do you
guys think do you think the dollar Hoff
created the curse himself or is it just
another one of the curses and the
arsenals of the most powerful Death
Eaters and if he did create the curse
himself do any spells charms or curses
come to mind that resemble it let me
know down in the comments section below
until next time you're a wizard Harry